[Music]
foreign
[Music]
and I am an author of algorithms and
data structures for massive data sets so
today I want to talk about hashing
either you know about it explicitly or
you're using it but you don't know that
you're using it so the question is why
did I decide to talk about hashing today
it's actually chapter 2 of our book and
there's two reasons for that uh one
reason is that hashing is a backbone for
all the system data structures in part
one that we talk about so
so on one hand hash it's it's kind of
good to know hashing starting this book
because it's a good review for the
chapters to come
however hash tables have also over time
been adapted to serving these massive
distributed systems and today we're
gonna look at one algorithm uh that is
for distributed hashing which is called
consistent hashing hashing is everywhere
and uh pretty much it's easier to kind
of find an application
it's much easier to find an application
that uses hashing than the one that
doesn't if you just think of an example
of how many times you use hashing
while you send an email uh first of all
when you log in the password is hashed
at the server and it's checked against
the database to verify a match right so
if there's a match then you can log in
as you write an email spell checker will
hash words to check whether something is
correctly spelled
um when you send an email uh each email
is kind of split into little packets and
each packet on it carries a hash a hash
of an IP destination IP address so if
it's a non-existing hash then the packet
bounces
and then on the arriving side when
somebody receives your email a spam
filter might use hashing to check
whether your email contains one of those
uh spam-like words to a client of
classified as spam
uh and pretty much with pretty much
anything I could give you and you know
an example of hashing being used in in
pretty much every application at least
two or three times
um one of the applications kind of more
modern applications when it comes to Big
Data and dealing with large data sets is
a deduplication
um the duplication is uh something
basically it's the process of removing
duplicates
and uh it's especially important in the
storage backup systems such as I don't
know Dropbox or data domain and
applications like that so basically what
happens there is if you're working for a
company like that then you might have a
very big client like Enterprise clients
and you might have a contract with them
where you are taking backups of their
data
so if between two consecutive snapshots
of data let's say between every 24 hours
uh you might notice that most of the
content like 99 or more of the content
is actually identical right people
modify some files uh but between you
know in a short time span not much
changes
and basically what they do is they're
saying well we're not going to store the
whole uh all of the data every new time
again uh first of all that takes a lot
of bandwidth and second of all that
takes a lot of space and it's just not a
smart thing to do so what they do is
when they're getting new files is they
use hashing to quickly identify what
they already have
so for example one such system is called
chunk stash
um and so when a new file arrives it's
split into these little chunks and you
might decide how big of a chunk you want
to have the smaller the chunk the finer
the granularity of your the duplication
and every chunk is hashed right so every
chunk has a little hash associated with
it and for each of those hashes you go
to Hash table and check whether you
already have it and if you don't have it
um then the new chunk and the chunk ID
are added both to the storage and to the
hash table
um however if you already have a chunk
ID then you just say okay this is a
duplicate we're not going to store this
so this is a um kind of a very common
thing that's um that's done nowadays in
systems like that and this process has
to be really fast you need to be really
quick at figuring out uh whether you
need a new chunk or not the duplication
is there is is kind of everywhere as
well
um it's not just in the storage backup
systems
um and actually something that was shown
to be uh at some point uh vulnerability
is uh it happened to users at some point
uh from what I understand is that they
try to upload like a huge file that
would normally need a lot of time to
upload and they would notice that they
would immediately get the message that
it's uploaded so that's kind of a
security vulnerability that I think was
fixed uh at some point
um because it would let you know that
somebody else has the same file
and if you have these little chunks
um then that's sensitive to small edits
of the file as well so
um the duplication is really
um is there's a lot of work on
optimizing the duplication processes
many places
um and actually in this duplication a
string matching algorithm as a string
hashing algorithm is used which is car
Praveen fingerprinting and this is one
of the fastest uh string matching
algorithms uh and part of the reason for
that is that it uses hashing right so
instead of comparing substrings actual
substrings it Compares hashes of sub
substrings
um and but I'm not going to go into more
detail about that you might already be
familiar with carp Raven it's kind of a
randomized really fast string matching
algorithm
so you might be thinking why we love
hash table so much right
um well first of all uh in short it
seems like a kind of a perfect
dictionary and why do I say perfect well
when you look at these other data
structures like arrays and linked lists
and binary search trees hash tables are
the only one that run in constant time
when it comes to lookup insert and
delete
um and so that's where the perfect comes
from however where does the illusion
come from well it's only expected right
so it doesn't offer the kind of
guarantee that a binary search tree
offers that you know operations will not
run longer than logarithmic time so in
hash tables the worst case is linear
time which is pretty terrible
and the reason for that is because many
items might map to the same Hash Hash
bucket which kind of turns your search
into a linear kind of search
however uh this worst case linear time
is not as bad
as
as you would say that let's say unsorted
arrays have a linear time search right
that's also true but that's not the same
worst case linear time because in the
case of arrays that worst case will
happen very consistently actually you
every time you look for something that's
not in the array you will get linear
time
however with hash tables if you have a
pretty good hash function it will happen
Almost Never
so it doesn't offer guarantees that are
constant time some versions of hash
tables do but interestingly those are
almost never implemented in real life
because they complicate the common case
and we'll see more about the importance
of common case in hash tables so there's
a kind of a ton of literature on hash
functions and there's a lot of
complicated math also in relation to
Hash function but the main thing to know
about it is that what hash function does
basically like a word is the same
sources hashbrowns so it kind of minces
and chops data into little pieces until
the point when whatever the original
data was is unrecognizable and there's a
lot of research on cryptographic hash
functions right so how do you send
something how do you hash something so
that nobody can figure out what is it
that you hashed
however for the purposes of what we're
talking about and we're massive data
structures we want much less from hash
functions we want simple and fast and
easy to evaluate hash functions and we
want the hash functions that distribute
data well in common cases one of the
examples of a set of hash functions that
gained a lot of popularity is the murmur
hash in originally invented by Austin
Appleby and I just want to show a little
example here
of murmur hash one of the wrappers of
mnh3 and here you have a function dot uh
sorry a method hash and hash 64 and hash
128 depending on however long a hash you
want to have and you can set the seed
whether you want a signed or unsigned
integer or even what kind of
architecture you have
um and the name a murmur hash came from
multiply plus rotate which are the main
things that uh main ways to uh chop and
mince data in this function
um so that's kind of a murmur hash has
been used a lot in these uh kind of
system data structures
uh But whichever way you look at it uh
hash functions are bound to introduce
collisions uh and that's because you're
mapping a huge Universe of potential
items to
um a much smaller set of hash table
buckets right so just by you know a
simple logic or pigeonhole principle if
you want to be mathematical about it uh
you will always have some items going to
the same bucket so that's kind of a bad
situation
um and to do that and to solve that
problem we have different Collision
resolution techniques and I'm kind of
assuming uh people mostly know about
these so I'm not going to explain them
too much I'm just showing two basic one
chaining and linear probing where
chaining Associates a linear uh linked
list with each bucket so all the items
that hash the particular bucket are
stored in one on list for example here
in position three you have b d and a and
once something again hashes to three
like C does here uh it's inserted at the
front of the chain now linear probing on
the other hand stores uh is a version of
something called open addressing and it
stores item inside the slots
and if the position where you hash the
stick and then you search downward for
the first available position to store an
item there are a lot more details to
this but for now let's say this is
enough and uh there's people have
researched about uh what's faster what
works better right and uh you have
serums saying that with high probability
these chains in the chaining table are
going to be lengths in the worst case no
longer than login over log log M so some
kind of a little bit less than
logarithmic length whereas the runs the
consecutive runs in linear probing are
going to be of lengths logarithmic
so a little bit longer why we care about
this well clearly this length is what
defines how long your search is going to
be and how long your delete is going to
be and so on and so forth
um and it kind of makes sense that the
linear probing here has these longer
runs because different items from
different buckets can participate in the
same run whereas in chaining only the
items from one bucket belong to a one
linked list
um so there's a lot of debate of you
know what's better and some methods like
I think C plus plus hash table unordered
map uses chaining I think even hashmap
in Java uses chaining but there's a lot
of criticism there as well because
chaining uses extra pointers which is a
lot of extra space
however what's really a kind of an
important detail that distinguishes
linear probing is that all the items in
linear probing are sequentially ordered
in memory so when you're fetching
something you're anyway fetching a whole
cache line so whether your run is you
know login or login over log log n or
one or a hundred it matters a little
less because you're doing one memory
access whereas in chaining you might be
doing many memory accesses because of
the way linked lists are laid out in
memory so a lot of the production hash
tables actually use linear probing so
for example if we look at how python
implements hash tables python uses uh
for their data structure addict uh which
is one of the most widely used python
data structures uh it uses a hash table
and uh if you are unfamiliar with dict
I'll just briefly show
um an example uh here I have a
dictionary in Python which is basically
a key value a set of key value pairs you
can't have duplicate keys but you can
have duplicate values uh and you have to
use keys that are hashable which means
it cannot be a mutable type it cannot be
a list it can be an integer a double a
tuple a string something like that so
here if I run this um
pythonict example you get that what the
items are what the keys are notice that
in Python hash of five is five so it's
not a very mysterious hash function
that's used
um
and so on and so forth